so anyway we're saying the meissner
effect as applied to these claimed high
temperature superconductors
in the experiments on the hydrates
people claim to have seen the first type
of experiment where if you apply a
magnetic field to a superconductor it
doesn't
go inside it gets repelled
but when they do the other experiment
which is a cool the system in the
presence of a magnetic field they don't
see a signal and
I think that's a red flag that says
these are not really superconductors
we'll see and it's sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
Magic
welcome to a very refreshing episode of
the into the impossible podcast
today we're joined by a renowned
physicist a condensed matter theorist
who happens to be the inventor of many
things including the indomitable the the
precariously named H index which I think
is named after his last name but this is
Professor Jorge Hirsch of the University
of California San Diego Jorge thank you
for coming on the show thank you for
inviting me Brian apologize for the
mix-up last time I was totally
unprofessional of me but I had a little
visitor as you remember and sometimes
these things happen but it's very
gracious and then come back time
commitment so
and uh this has been a couple months
coming since the announcement of a major
Discovery in the annals of physics which
could go down as one of the greatest
discoveries of all time it could be
worthy of a Nobel Prize or it could be
flawed it could be a fraud it could be
many many things that we are looking to
you for interpretation
uh so the first thing I want to ask you
is when did you become aware of these
results uh the first time uh what sort
of is the is the impact of
superconductivity on physics and what
does this all mean help us interpret it
we're just simple cosmologists around
here you mean when I became aware of
which results the Diaz at all or the
group ideas originally and got you
interested in this in this particular
yeah well on October
um 14 2020 uh yes and co-workers
published the paper
uh with a tighter room temperature
superconductivity in carbon measure
sulfur hydrate and so I the same day I
saw it and became extremely interested
in it because
as you well said superconductors are
fascinating and they are basically
macroscopic Quantum systems and if we
have them at room temperature then it's
just amazing what you can do with it now
of course that paper
um
was room temperature but also very very
high pressures and so that makes it a
lot
less interesting but still it's an
enormous breakthrough because we have
been looking for room temperature
superconductors for a hundred and twenty
years or so
and the promise of those uh room
temperature superconductors will
demonstrate here this is not a room
temperature superconductor this is a
piece of yitrium copper barium oxide
sometimes called yibaco which needs to
be cooled below its superconducting
transition temperature which is
approximately 90 Kelvin so this is 77
Kelvin which of course is very balmy
compared to what we do in the cosmic
microwave background but nevertheless if
you could have such a device if you
could have a true levitating device let
me see I'm going to get some more liquid
nitrogen but describe the history of
superconductivity and what does a
theoretical condensed matter physicist
do and I'm just going to go get some all
right it's a long story yes discovered
experimentally in 1911
and it was immediately realized but it's
discovered coming on so this is an
amazing thing that the resistance of a
metal when you cool instead of gradually
going down
at one point it suddenly drops to
exactly zero
and exactly zero means that if you set
up a current going it will keep going
forever
so it's really qualitatively zero not
quantitatively only and
of course
from day one it was very important to
understand why this happens and
how can you make this happen at a higher
temperature and so for that we need to
understand why it happens and what
characteristics of the material favor
this phenomenon and how can you modify
the materials to make it happen at
higher temperatures so the original
Discovery was at
a Mercury at 4 Kelvin I believe and then
people started working experimentally on
trying to increase it and gradually went
up to 23 Kelvin over about the next 40
years or 50 years
and the next big jump came actually only
in 1986 with a high temperature
superconductors where the temperature
went from 23 Kelvin all the way to 90
and Beyond
so why bco which is the one you have is
90 Kelvin which breaks the nitrogen
barriers so liquid nitrogen is much
cheaper than liquid helium and so this
of course was a big breakthrough
and then the temperature went up all the
way up to 140 or 150 for these materials
right so as I say it's a very long story
let me try to shorten it the the thing
is in 1957 a theory of superconductivity
was proposed
which um
is called the BCS theory that is
believed to describe what's called
conventional superconductors
and it's generally accepted to describe
all superconductors at low temperatures
that were known at the time
and others but not these high
temperature superconductors recuperates
okay and so the conventional theory is
based on one basic
interaction which is called the electron
phonon interaction which says that
electrons will do this remarkable thing
if they pair up and in order for pair up
you need an effective attraction between
them
in that the bcsc research results from
the motion of the ions as the electrons
move they move the ions and in turn that
creates an effective attraction between
electrons
so
it's an essential part of the theory and
the one thing then it predicts is that
for lighter ions you will get higher
temperature superconductors
and so as you know hydrogen is the
lightest
atom we have so the theory predicts that
if you can make
superconducting materials or materials
that have a lot of hydrogen
you will get higher critical
temperatures and there was a seminal
paper by Ashcroft in 1968 where she
specifically proposed to look for
metallic hydrogen
which is hydrogen pressed to enormous
density so that it becomes metallic that
hasn't been achieved yet
but then in 2004 he proposed that
if you mix up hydrogen with some other
metals you'll have an internal chemical
pressure and you can achieve this high
temperature superconducting state if you
have an hydrogen
compound it's called the hydride that
has a lot of hydrogen and some other
metallic elements and so the at that
point experimentally people
started working very hard to create
these materials and they need to be
created under pressure or at least it's
easier and so the focus has been on this
Hydra materials under pressure is that
to make the hydride form or is that to
mimic the rep replicate some phonon
interactions
to make it be a metal the hydrogens have
to be the material has to be
sufficiently dense and usually for
example if you have
sulfur hydride it's a gas it's not a
metal and then you
apply very very high pressures to it and
it starts conducting electricity
and in fact that material was claimed in
2015 to be the first hydride high
temperature superconductor that was
discovered oh is it a copper was it also
a copper hydrant no no no no copper so
we need to make a clear difference
between the cup rates which is what you
have there which we know are
so-called high temperature
superconductors but high temperature
means up to 150 Kelvin
and the hydrates that are claimed to be
superconducting up to room temperature
and
the big difference that I must say is
important is the following for the
cooperates everybody agrees that the
interaction causing superconductivity is
not the electron found on BCS
interactions
there are no Cooper Pairs and there are
coupons but they are not Financial
formed they're not generated by this
electron ion interaction so the mass of
the ions is irrelevant there is other
mechanisms that people have proposed
which we can talk to if you want to but
they are not related to the electron
phoner interaction instead
the Hydra materials people believe that
it is the original BCS electron phonon
mechanism that's driving the
superconductivity there so it's kind of
paradoxical
that you know before the Hydraulics were
thought that there was no way to get
high TC with a conventional conform
mechanism and you need to find another
mechanism like in the culprits and then
suddenly the conventional mechanism
became again the driving
hey friends just a quick request while
you're enjoying this video to leave a
thumbs up my thumb's a little bit
preoccupied with all Carl Sagan over
here but I hope yours is free enough to
leave a like it really helps me with the
algorithm and for extra credit homework
assignment leave a comment down below
what you're enjoying about this video
now back to the show
and what have been your contributions in
this field uh you know I know about a
great deal of your work as a condensed
matter theorist but uh we haven't had
many of those on the podcast in fact
we've only had Felix flicker recently on
but um uh he was one of the first uh
theoretically against metaphysicists
what do you do what is first of all
condensed matter physics Anderson came
up with that name
um is it a good name
uh I don't know I mean he wanted to
generalize it from solid state physics
and it's
whatever you think I don't think it's
particularly necessary but whatever so I
am interested in actual solids as
opposed to more General conditions well
well not quite but like for example
liquid crystals would be some condensed
model that's not the solid but the
so
my interest is in
Collective phenomena in solids due to
electrons deciding to somehow do
something together as opposed to moving
independently and superconductivity is
clearly
one such phenomenon other phenomena have
to do with magnitude for example why
iron is a magnet and
aluminum is not things like that right
but so
initially in my career I was focusing on
General kind of
correlated
states of electrons in solids but then
starting more or less like 30 years ago
I focused
very much on superconductivity
so because you have a DOT edu email
address you are eligible to receive this
piece of iron also Cobalt nickel any
guess where this might have come from
Jorge
you didn't even have to join my mailing
list at Brian keating.com
this came from outer space cool so this
is magnetic material cool which has come
from outer space and it is highly
magnetized you can put it on there and
you might not be able to get it back see
it jumped up Stuart get us on camera on
my camera please so we can show the demo
here so you will get your own piece of
space dust if you had to have a DOT edu
email address because I love to reach
out and I will give this one to you so
you didn't have to join my email list
although the next time I come you'll
send me a superconductor from outer
space that's what I'm going to ask you
so could it be that there are
superconductors in space could it be uh
maybe not tangentially related perhaps
to our issues of Dark Matter there are
those who propose that dark matter could
be a superfluid including people like uh
past guest Stefan Alexander Justin Curie
Sabina hasenfelder what do you think
about the superfluid have you ever paid
attention to it and not very closely but
I do agree because I paid a little bit
of attention to superfluid helium which
is a material we have on Earth
which has some very close similarities
with superconductors and some important
differences but the the basic phenomenon
which
share they share and I suspect in this
other
ideas and cosmology is microscopic
Quantum coherence
Quantum coherence phase coherence at the
microscopic scale that's what defines a
superconductor and a superfluid
now when I look at the the field of you
know so I still sometimes lapse and call
it solid state physics
um I remember it was called squalid
State physics and that's why Anderson
repeatedly wanted to perhaps change it
although nevertheless
um I see a lot of acrimony and it
reminds me of some of the guests I've
had uh on the podcast that we talk about
Consciousness and I ask them what is
consciousness and what is possible to be
conscious and they'll say things like an
electron or a monkey or in other words
they can't really Define it there's a
famous essay by Thomas Nagel called
what's it like to be a bat the end he
says we don't know
um so when I look at superconductivity
it's pretty clear they talk about a
couple of classical tests for what is a
superconductor absence of electrical
resistivity critical temperature
critical
um critical magnetic field Curie
temperatures things like that and then
there's things you know subtle things
like magnetic induction and and so forth
that we'll talk about
um for these claims it seems pretty
clear-cut you could just here's a chunk
of material give give you some of it and
you can see if it has resistance cool at
room temperature even even you know a
theorist can do that no offense but you
could do that I'll give you the
voltmeter down the hall and uh and we'll
be able to get it but um so what is so
suspicious about it what tests do these
high temperature superconductors fail in
your expert opinion well
I mean the main problem with this
hydraulic superconductors is that
you have to apply very high pressure and
actually that was the case until the
latest announcement in March that we'll
talk about but before that pressures
were
of around 200 gigapascal or at least
over 100 gigapascal and for those High
pressures you need a diamond and whistle
and you need to have a very small sample
which is maybe at most 50 microns in
diameter and a few microns in thickness
and so there are tough experiments and
when you measure things
um first of all there's a lot of
background that signals that can come in
and
uh
it's just very difficult to for example
when you measure transport resistance
what you really want is resistivity
which is
an intensive property as opposed to
resistance that depends on the size of
your sun right and if you look at all
these hydrated materials they usually
give you resistance but they don't talk
about resistivity because and that's
just for my audience am I not be
familiar with resistance per unit length
essentially per unit length in the unit
area and so on and because there is
difficulty in knowing exactly what is
the size of the sample and the geometry
and so on
it's hard to estimate the resistivity
and so if you really could demonstrate
okay the resistivity of this is two or
three or four orders of magnitude less
than that of a good metal that would be
very convincing but that's people don't
do that in the experiments right also
the experiments are not very
reproducible you do it once you get one
result even the same lab does it again
they get
a different result at a different
temperature a drop sometimes it drops to
very small values sometimes it drops to
finite values
and what's interesting is that of course
some reasons the the experiment I seem
not to be very
critical of the tests they do in the
sense
in my opinion they rely very much on
Theory so if it's a theory calculation
tells them there has to be
superconductivity in this material they
see some drop
in resistance and they say okay that's
it we have found superconductivity even
if the resistance then go to zero they
attribute that to well maybe there is
some contact or some contact resistance
or some part of the sample that didn't
go superconducting and they do not I
believe take into account that there is
other reasons why a material under high
pressure can undergo changes in
resistance that are not
superconductivity but dramatically so in
the demonstrations that we'll talk about
it seems like there is a qualitative
difference between an ordinary you know
axial stress strain dependent resistance
or resistivity and these kind of you
know near zero or close to zero
resistivity measurements that they claim
to have demonstrated although we can't
say for sure because they're not
replicatable right now right first
they're not repetitive then when you
look at the papers
very often they don't tell you whether
they are subtracting what they call the
background resistance yes
in particular if you look at the latest
paper uh
on this luticium nitroen hydride
you look at figure 15 they show you
curves that uh
drop and go to zero and continue zero
but they happen to be honest enough
because and that's probably because of
the history with this group to say well
we subtracted background resistance
and they don't show you what the raw
data looks like but they did upload the
raw data at the website because they
were required to do so by nature and if
you now take those raw data and plot
them
that same plot that in the paper looks
like this and then zero looks like
gradually coming down and doing nothing
okay
and it's obviously no evidence for
superconductivity but after you subtract
something it looks like
superconductivity and you know famously
in my field of astronomy you know Edwin
Hubble uh published in 1929 the
proceedings of the National Academy of
Sciences the plot of the recession of
velocities of galaxies versus distance
and thus a particular plot these data
will show this on the b-roll background
film that will show along with the paper
from Diaz group uh the figure that you
mentioned and he plots it and he shows
these data points and they're just boxes
there's no error bars the y-axis instead
of being labeled kilometers per second
just says kilometers and there's some
there's some strange scale and he fits a
line through it okay so famously this is
Hubble's Law the slope of that line it
goes through it's as simple as law
possible goes to zero the slope is now
called Hubble's Constant H which you
would love a little or actually we lose
little H in many varieties throughout
all the physics from Planck's constant
all the way up to reduced public
constant now
he also got the slope Wrong by a factor
of seven but is that important because
the general law is of course correct and
it holds over not just uh the the 10 to
50 Mega parsix that he looked at it
holds to thousands of megaparsecs so
what's wrong with this her Jorge I mean
just to be Devil's Advocate if if indeed
look this is you know very close to zero
resistance uh they're making a plot
they're subtracting stuff yeah but even
a great Hubble uh could make error
errors is this just a petty thing that
scientists care about because of you
know error bars here one thing doesn't
prove that the fact that Hubble turn out
to be right it's great yes the question
is is this true or not true in science
we deal with facts either this is a
superconductor or it's not a
superconductor I'm convinced it's not a
superconductor for many reasons okay
let's go through them okay and so it's
something that needs to be determined
it's not a question like in
other social sciences or political
sciences where there can be different
opinions here we will have an answer all
right
the long list of reasons why I don't
believe in this yeah it's very low as
long as you like
well it starts with a group that is
publishing this paper on the surface the
paper looks impressive it has a lot of
different measurements for
superconductivity resistance AC
susceptibility DC susceptibility
specific heat so all right
now
about this group we need to remember
that they published their first claim of
room temperature superconducted in 2020
the paper was retracted in September
2022. why was that retracted
it depends what you ask if you ask a
journal what they published is that they
retracted it because it was not they
used a non-standard procedure to
subtract the background from the raw
data
to arrive at the published data
if you ask me and Durk Vander Mario we
work together on this it is because what
they claim are the raw data that they
measured in the laboratory
are not measured they are fabricated
fabrication so we should stop there for
a second that's perhaps one of the most
serious charges in academic could have
leveled against them and you have
substantial reason to believe that uh
but as yet we're still this is open to
you know to debate they can respond to
this video I've actually asked them to
come on not today but come on the
podcast anytime I know you've
corresponded with him but just for my
listeners I have a lot of young you know
PhD students that listen to 100 000 plus
strong undergraduates who are thinking
about becoming condensed matter
physicists this is extremely serious and
and I think to have someone of Jorge's
caliber open honest and vulnerable
enough to discuss this is a very rare
treat for my audience so I just want to
you know put a double click on that and
say this is an extremely serious
allegation from an extremely serious
group of scientists here against another
group
um uh where there's no there's no
monetary you're not doing this for fame
for attention uh you're really quite a
private person
so explain what this means that that it
that they're potentially so we published
two papers with Dirk and in fact
I wrote the third paper just four pages
trying to concisely show mathematically
that this is fabricated that paper was
published today coincidentally really
yeah on the journal chemical
Communications okay as a comment on a
paper that they published in chemical
Communications last year on the same
material CSH
that was the
was the subject of the nature paper that
was retracted so in this paper
um
I published it as a comment it was
reviewed for seven months
and the authors were invited to write a
reply explaining
why they don't agree with what I'm
saying in the paper and they have not
provided a satisfactory reply to a
journal and the journal decided to
publish my comment without a reply I am
sure that the journal will publish a
reply if they submit one
but and I know my audience subscribes to
this journal I'm sure that they do but
let's summarize what are the concl the
some of the some of the pieces of
evidence that you bring against it
mathematically physically Etc yeah so
they
give
so the susceptibility
uh uh shows a drop where the system goes
superconducting susceptibility versus
temperature okay explain susceptibility
as a magnetic phenomena magnetic
susceptibility means the response to the
system when you apply a magnetic field
when the system becomes superconducting
it responds differently than when it's
normal in particular it doesn't like the
magnetic field to penetrate inside
its body so I generate diamagnet it
generates a current that prevents a
magnetic field it Shields the magnet
unlike this meteorite or the one I've
given you which is highly that's exactly
the opposite ferromagnetic exactly they
couldn't be more opposite highly dire
magnetic yes precisely go on and so you
measure that susceptibility which
goes to a large negative value so the as
a function of temperature there is a
drop when this happens
now because of this being a very small
sample they have a background signal
that they need to subtract and so what
they publish in the paper
is the
raw data minus the background signal
okay
and that's called the signal so signal
or
yeah data equals raw data minus
background signal
all right so the data that they
published have a very very peculiar
structure and so we asked I asked them
to provide the raw data and the
background signal in order to
understand whether these are real
and so it turns out that the
data
can be expressed by mathematical
formulas so the data versus temperature
there is to be specific
450 data points
that are given to eight decimal places
we can we can represent those 450 data
points to eight decimal places by
the sum of two mathematical functions
one is a series of integer steps
multiplied by one number which happens
to be 0.16555
and the other function is a set of third
order polynomials that can be a
figure out what they are they can I stop
you for one second eight decimal places
so you're talking about uh tens of Nano
um this would be Nano orc unit of
magnetic susceptibility well no they
measure voltage so okay yeah oh so okay
so that's that's the reason so but they
converted to a number I mean are they
saying they trust all those numbers I
mean the implication Jorge let's be
honest is that this is this is fit I
mean they've basically constructed them
no no but it doesn't matter whether you
trust them or not okay they say
that they measure this row voltage to
eight decimal places
what I'm saying is that I can
mathematically calculate that row
voltage
by
using my formulas and so if you take 450
and multiply by eight
how much is that 3 000 or 700 000 yeah
that's the number of digits you need to
reproduce your results now in my in my
formula instead of 3000 digits I need
like 100 digits okay to reproduce those
three signs of digits that they say they
measured
okay I I don't think
you can explain that does that happen
for any other super like if you just
took this superconductor I mean could
you make some function and say if you do
let's say an alien or an artificial
intelligence machine learning algorithm
you give it the magnetization then it
says here you go we fit to it and oh
that's what uh that's where the Cooper
pairs form or something like that is it
is impossible you would be fitting these
you know measurements of noise and so
each one of these points has some noise
yeah and they give me the numbers
including the noise and I have a
mathematical formula that can fit the
noise and of course it's impossible okay
so that's the d That's DC or IC
magnetization this is AC susceptibility
which is measured by measuring a voltage
in a coil with a voltmeter and all these
have to be done in the diamond Anvil
cell in other words once you do it are
there I mean this is a side note but if
you let's say you put them in the Anvil
and then press them and then there was
some you know plastic deformation and it
just remained ever forever these things
don't have that phenomena in other words
you have to continuously apply pressure
you do although this pressure is not so
high right this paper it's not so high
right but in the in the retracted paper
the CSH it was very high 200 GPA but yes
these materials if you release the
pressure they don't stay they stay they
don't stay sorry right so going back to
the reasons so one reason is
look I can understand if people make
mistakes I can understand if there is
one member of a big group that does
something that wasn't quite proper but
to have the principal investigators
refuse to answer questions about how was
this obtained and explained so that one
can reproduce what they say that was
measured I don't think it's acceptable
and that's why I cannot believe what
they are saying now or trust what they
are saying because
they haven't responded to those very
factual questions so this speaks to
their to their integrity as experimental
scientists one of the greatest and
biggest challenges that a physicist has
in an experimental field is not the
measurement of a quantity like Hubble
showed it's the errors that you ascribe
to that and there are two different
types of errors that can be ascribed
there are statistical errors which can
get better with repeated measurements of
the same quantity and then there are
systematic errors which must be removed
if and only if you can do another
experiment that gets rid of the thumb on
the scale or the excess resistivity
surely these people they're an eminent
institution in Rochester I mean they
must know the concept of an error budget
do they break out the statistical and
the systematic errors I covered some of
their findings I showed their data in my
previous video which which we'll get to
because you had some criticism that I do
want to learn what I did wrong because
I'm always trying to improve and I can't
resist with such an imminent colleague
that as yourself to I need to know what
I did wrong but I don't remember that
that they actually separated out the in
their and provide an error budget so
that's a huge red flag that I would
think nature although you know what the
saying is about nature just because it's
in nature doesn't necessarily mean it's
wrong
but it was also in the New York Post and
in other journals so so tell us what are
some of the other uh red flags
all right so that's
for this particular paper the main red
flag now
um
all right so I'm sorry to interrupt her
all right but let's say it didn't let's
say the magnetic susceptibility is kind
of wanky and whatnot but but let's say
it still has zero resistivity uh let's
stipulate that
um how do we expect stipulate that well
I mean it after yourself
right so after they subtract it so
there's two there's multiple cascading
errors is what is what's contract
background they show in this latest
paper they show curves yes where they
show one curve that is very broad the
resistance versus temperature and then
they say this is due to sampling
homogeneities which happen in these
small cells and that sounds reasonable
and then they show another curve where
the curves are a thousand times narrower
so the transition is incredibly Sharp
and uh you don't expect that in a
reasonable experiment making the samples
the same way that suddenly the width of
the transition will change by a factor
of a thousand wow another red flag is
that they measure voltage versus current
but they don't seem to find the critical
current it kind of Rises slowly from
zero while in superconductors you expect
that if you're at low temperatures for a
small voltage you get uh so for small
current you measure voltage versus
current you have no voltage and then at
one point you have a threshold and you
start developing voltage they don't see
that either there's a critical current
all right sorry to interrupt but is it
essentially a different manifestation of
a critical magnetic field absolutely
okay so absolutely okay let us figure
out yeah by some famous person way back
yes yes there's a relation between them
and
um so again so now it's multiple I was
envisioning that perhaps it is that you
know it has zero resistivity I mean can
you imagine such a thing could you
imagine something that doesn't have a
critical field or we can't measure its
critical field let's say completely
different group you know I come up my
kid comes down makes a superconductor or
your daughter or whatever can you
imagine is it possible like what would
they call such a material no
superconductor system properties that
are common to all superconductors
immutable now there is some properties
that can be different but there's some
basic things that are the same you need
to have a critical current and you need
to have zero resistance below that
the one other property that's very
important and interesting What's called
the meissner effect as you know
and there is two aspects of the Micron
effect that people sometimes confuse
which is one thing is to have a
superconductor and apply a magnetic
field and the magnetic field doesn't
penetrate and that's what happens if I
take a magnet and put it on top of an
existing superconductor and it floats
all right so we'll do that experiment
now okay
hopefully this will
this will work but you know we've had
budget cuts right it's sort of floating
okay let me try another one
and it floats in a very different way by
the way does it not Jorge than just a
normal magnet right so if I had a normal
magnet let's see this remember my magnet
cannot be in equilibrium with another
magnet there is something called
earnshow's theorem and that prevents it
unless it's an AC current right if the
AC current you could do it but these DC
magnets there we go yeah all right so
now the hope of course is that we are
calibrated high temperature super not
high temperature it's a higher
temperature uh that superconducts that's
one of these cup rates and it could be
used and the hope is that'll be used for
a magnetic levitation and we'll get to
your hopes and dreams for truly room
temperature super connectivity in uh
towards the very end we talk about
magical Technologies and whatnot let's
see how long that goes so we're talking
about this theorem that prevents an
ordinary magnet like this refrigerator
magnet keychain this could not do that
nor could this ferromagnetic meteorite
that I've given you uh but we could put
people on top of this thing and turn it
into a frictionless uh or mostly
frictionless travel mechanism so anyway
we're saying the meissner effect as
applied to these claimed high
temperature superconductors let's
continue yes let's see
um
yeah I was going to clarify an important
distinction in the meissner effect the
one thing is to have a superconductor
and bring it close to a magnet and get
this repulsion that makes it levitate a
somewhat different process is where you
have the magnet close to the normal
metal when it's not cold yet
and let's say I take a piece of metal
that's going to become super conducting
but it's not super conducting I put the
magnet on top it just rests on it and
now I cool
the system
so that's a different phenomenon flux
trapping because no because here
Faraday's law plays a big role when
you're bringing the superconductor of
the magnet close together it is an
induction due to Faraday's law in the
experiment I'm describing you're just
cooling and there is no change from
external change and by itself the
superconductor will develop a current
not induced by Faraday's law that will
make the magnet rise so that it expels
the flux
and that is an important distinction of
the two experiments and
in the experiments on the hydrides
people uh
claim to have seen the first type of
experiment where if you apply a magnetic
field to a superconductor it doesn't
go inside it gets repelled
but when they do the other experiment
which is a cool the system in the
presence of a magnetic field they don't
see a signal and
I think that's a red flag that says
these are not really superconductors and
um
we'll see how much of the technological
application could we get from a low
resistivity but not maybe not zero
resistivity room temperature ambient
pressure material would that be as
Revolution I mean it certainly would be
as revolutionary um look I think there's
really
a qualitative difference between zero
resistance and small resistance and I
don't think
it's actually feasible
technologically to get non-zero small
resistances either we succeed in making
room temperature superconductors or we
don't binary and if we do it's going to
have lots of very important consequences
yeah I'm not the right person I know but
what are you interested so here's my
knockout I'll be uh I'll play Devil's
Advocate again I hear a lot about
quantum computers and how important they
are and what they're able to do and we
heard that the quantum computer
teleported a wormhole and or to con
there's a lot of hype inside and and and
it's particularly strong in what I do
rare in what you do
um but let's say uh the you know you can
make a superconductor what would that
mean I've always heard you know a
Feynman talked about this and I remember
reading about it in the 80s and 90s he
said you know quantum computers are
really good at uh describing quantum
mechanical hamiltonians and lagrangias
so okay that's great if you I mean I
don't happen to need that for my iPhone
uh so is that really true and and then
what what is a quantum computer good
good for as far as your concerns look
I'm not an expert in Quantum Computing I
can well imagine that if we are ever
going to make a quantum computer it's
going to be with superconductors because
superconductors are microscopic Quantum
systems and if anybody has chance of
making a quantum computer it's a system
of superconducting
Josephson Junctions or whatever
and but you know just the
the the
just having room temperature look when
the transistor when the transistor was
discovered back in 1950 it wasn't clear
either that it will be everywhere in you
know 15 million of them just exactly
that's exactly what would happen with
superconductors I mean initially maybe
you don't quite realize what it's going
to it's going to change the world
if uh so the question is
is it possible okay
and and how do we get there and that's
the key question
and so that's the question that I think
the community is in the wrong track and
all this
enormous effort and money that is being
spent in these hydride superconductor
research is misplaced in my opinion okay
so let's talk about that uh
incentivization people think of us as
scientists as we were just very
dispassionate we just care about the
truth we stroke you have a beard I'm I'm
still kind of trying to grow a beard
like yours Jorge and we just
really just think about what's good for
nature and what Mother Nature or God or
whatever will reveal to us so
um I always think that's kind of bogus I
mean scientists have very good qualities
and we have very
um many say Petty or less highly uh
refined characters yeah let's talk about
so
the the propensity for for hype is is
huge especially in this in this little
yeah so talk about that what is what is
what do you think of we're not we're
doctors you and I but we're not
psychotherapists so what do you think is
going on is it a fraud I'll read from
this New York Times article I don't and
this is from Doctor struggle as trouble
says I don't want to read too much into
it but there could be a pattern of
behavior here he's talking about Diaz he
really could be the best high pressure
physicist in the world poised to win a
Nobel Prize and you know how I feel
about the Nobel Prize or there's
definitely something else going on same
article by you Jorge Hirsch his
complaints about the ass Guru so
persistent and strided that others in
the field later uh circulated a letter
complaining about Decades of disruptive
behavior by Jorge Hirsch but Jorge said
in my opinion the junk sometimes become
conclusions what did you mean by that
they never said that that says well this
is the New York Times article never said
that young becomes conclusions no let's
talk about what that yes that's it there
is a letter that in fact the New York
Times editor sent to me
that I hadn't seen before apparently has
been circulating over the last four or
five months
claiming that for the past 30 years I
have
been doing disruptive behavior
which I yes I would like to respond to
it yeah and the person that wrote the
letter has not made their name public or
is it a lot of signs as far as I know
but I know some people that received it
and so on
well the disruptive behavior refers to
the fact that
yes starting in 1989
I suddenly
discovered a different way to expand
superconductivity
um
at the time we were all trying to
understand the Cup race that had been
discovered in 1986 and I came up with an
idea of how to understand the cooperates
and immediately saw that that same idea
can explain all superconductors not just
the cooperates which would mean that the
electron phonon mechanism that is part
of the conventional Theory does not
really apply it's not responsible for
superconductivity in any material I came
to the conclusion back in 1989 and so
since then I've been working on that a
long time
but it you know I have made a lot of
progress and it took me like a very long
time to
and the sensors and things in particular
the meissner effect that they were
studying you about which I finally
understood only like six years ago or so
all based on the same basic idea that is
different from the conventional idea now
my understanding has a lot in common
with the conventional Theory but it has
some fundamental differences anyway ever
since I came to a realization I've been
writing papers developing the theory
and questioning the validity of the
conventional Theory and that
has not gained me a lot of friends I
have had very much trouble publishing
the results
I have published a lot of papers on this
but not on the most highly you know
prestigious papers the journalists like
science or nature
and
um
and so
for reasons I don't quite understand the
theory is not considered
valid by many people I think some people
find it interesting but
people what happens in science is
people don't address questions for
example they just ignore so if I write
the paper saying
the BCS conventional Theory cannot
explain the meissner effect for this
reason and this reason and this reason
in order to explain the major effect you
need to have this physics that the
conventional Theory simply doesn't have
sometimes we solve problems and I don't
have to tell you this in quantum
mechanics or classical mechanics by
doing separation of variables okay we
take the radial part we separate the
radial part from the angular asymmetal
and polar angle why combine both the
refutation of the BCS Theory with a
concomitant new Theory why not separate
those variables
um
we can
but I've tried to do that too I've
written papers simply addressing what's
wrong with BCS here and that's not
accepted no really no people simply
ignore them those papers so the
conventional wisdom for my audience is
saying that the BCS Theory it
co-invented by my graduate quantum
mechanics professor at Brown University
Leanne Cooper who's still very much
alive and well yes uh allegedly on the 4
train in in Brooklyn in 1957 or whatever
that that theory is incapable of of
explaining one of the Hallmarks of
superconductivity in fact one of the
motivations for the demonstration that's
what you're calling myself in particular
expulsion of magnetic fields yes are
there any unique observables or
experiments that could be done to either
falsify the BCF BCS Theory or to
motivate your theory
yeah there are experiments that could be
done to validate what I'm saying happens
in superconductors that have not been
done
the physics I'm talking about is
extremely simple maybe I can even try to
explain it to you
a superconductor as I say when it goes
from normal to superconductor will expel
magnetic fields in order to do that
it has to start generating a current
near the surface that generates a
magnetic field opposite to the one
that's applied from lenses law and no or
no no are they no really it's actually
the opposite of lenses law really okay
lenses law says that the metal wants to
oppose changes in magnetic flux
okay and so you start with a metal that
has magnetic flux in it lenses law says
it doesn't want to change that instead
One Step It Takes parasites it does
exactly the opposite of what lux's law
tells is it should be doing I was
conflating expel with no it's very
important yeah it is important because
it says if for some reason somebody
wants to expel those lines lets us
lawsuit oppose it okay
and I'm saying BCS theory has no
explanation of how you generate that
current opposing lenses law doing the
opposite of what electromagnetism
once when we write down the Schrodinger
equation in for the Cooper pairs I mean
how do we make the quantum the classical
transition I mean where a current is
something macroscopic we don't usually
think about currents and quantum
mechanical terms in the Schrodinger
equation how does that operationally
occur again I'm a simple cosmology
experimentalist so but I know it must
involve some
there must be some transition between
the quantum and the classical region no
well you can write the current operator
in Quantum yeah right compute the
expectation value and the time Evolution
and so on and that will give you the
classical and the problem is in the BCS
calculation they don't do
the actual calculation of the process
whereby you start with the magnetic
field inside because that's very hard to
do all they do is they compute the
energy of the state when the magnetic
field is out already and they find that
it is lower than the energy of
not having expelled the magnetic field
but that is not enough and so this is an
energy argument right you need to
explain momentum conservation and how do
you go from here to there charge
conservation yeah the explanation is
extremely simple let me tell you because
it's very simple it's something that
anybody can understand
it's based on
the following Lawrence Force as you know
tells us that when a charge moves there
is a velocity
there's a force use the magnetic field
that is a cross product of velocity
times magnetic field correct
if you look at the superconductor
and you think about what happens if
electrons were to be flowing from the
inside outward as it goes
superconducting you will find that the
Lorenz force will deflect those
electrons and create a current that will
expel the magnetic field
that is a very simple concept and it
tells you that the transition to
superconductivity has to be associated
with the motion
expelling
electrons
very simple concept that is totally
exclusive too right yeah yeah it's
foreign to the conventional BCS series
that says none of that takes place no
pairs now I say now you also need pairs
to get everything to work but this basic
phenomenon that unless you have a radial
charge flow it's almost a mathematical
theorem that if you don't have radial
charge flow you cannot
opposed lenses law yeah as a consequence
of the curl it's basically what happens
in plasmas in plasmas there is something
called Alvin serum I don't know if you
know that elephant was a professor yeah
of course I do because the Nobel Prize
yep among other things for Elephants
theorem that is basically just saying
when you have a conducting fluid and
magnetic field lines are moving in it is
because the fluid is moving with the
field line so there is motion of charge
and Mass
when the magnetic field has moved
so that basic concept is missing in the
in the convention convention
understanding I see now another wrinkle
um in this story is the
um is the intellectual property rights
that Diaz and and his company have
asserted so he's created a company
called unearthly materials and you know
Jorge you and I are are public you know
University professors uh we don't get
paid that much but we do what we do
because we love it
um but you know if an opportunity came
along to you know patent some I have two
patents I've got pictures of them
somewhere I've made exactly zero dollars
for my two pets uh but but tell me
um is that a red flag honestly to you it
isn't to me but but
in the in the context that we are they
are using that as an excuse to not share
samples
of course this can be settled in in one
day I mean the latest claim they can
just ship a sample to our colleague
Brian Maple that has been doing
experiments on superconductors Academy
member former chair 60 years maybe or 50
years and he could check in a day
whether this is true or not they say
because of proprietary interests of the
company they cannot do that so
how can you patent an element or you
know a compound like this I think you
can so there have been patent fights
over ybco as far as I know really yes
really so I can't just go out and
synthesize my own I mean also there's
another wrinkle which is that there's a
stoichiometric factors and you know I
failed uh high school chemistry so I
can't even remember this but there are
these deltas and you know it seems like
the recipe is like one day you can get a
souffle and the next day you get a
chicken salad they say one third of the
time they get the Supercar two-thirds
they get chicken crap yeah but yeah look
and I don't know yeah we are we're
talking for a long time yes a lot of
other things I wanted yeah please God we
don't have the time or what we have a
lot of trouble with archive I don't know
if you know that I know about that I
know you were banned for six months
allegedly because of uh the The Improv
well you explain why why what was the
reason they gave that because I'm
extremely upset instantly upset with the
whole situation with archive I submitted
the paper to physical see the journal in
August 2021 because for eight months I
was trying to get the raw data for the
the susceptibility measurements and they
were refusing to give them out
claiming patent reasons that were
totally transparently
not applicable because this is just a
simple measurement right so I wrote this
paper to physical C I sent physical C
saying um
these are just probable fraud
that was the title of the paper the
title of the page so archive got that
paper and they put it on hold which I
totally understand they want to think
about it's a tricky thing all right one
month later physicacy publishes online
and another month later after the
archive moderators had considered it and
thought about it I didn't know anything
I'd let them do their job they posted it
online so that means they cleared
whatever moderation standards they have
so they posted online in October
magically then in December they wrote to
me saying that my papers are improper
and they are saying things that accuse
of people of Fraud and so they removed
the paper
and my first question is well you know
you analyze the paper for two months and
then you posted it so it's your problem
it's not my problem if the paper is not
something you think is improper and at
the same time what was happening is they
finally had released a rotate ideas at
all and I started analyzing them and I
found immediately that they were very
clear anomalies with the raw data and so
early December I submitted two papers to
Archive not saying fraud simply doing a
very dry analysis of the raw data saying
that there's a problem here and they
claimed you had gotten that data via
some means no no no no no the raw data
were published okay and co-workers on
archive in early December so immediately
after they were posted not just for me
for everybody I started analyzing them
and I sent them some papers with the
analysis now I was
careful because I
and didn't say anything like for they
still say no we're not going to post it
so they didn't post anything I kept
sending them papers and then sometime in
early February they banned me for six
months because they said I was doing
improper things so there's several
things that are wrong here I think
which is Diaz was publishing you know
his raw data and claiming that they are
valid I'm analyzing the raw data and
have mathematical analysis that shows a
normal list that I think the community
should consider archive decides no you
cannot publish that and you got banned
and then I get banned for six months
right exactly so and you couldn't appeal
no of course I tried to appeal it but it
didn't go anywhere right right
so I believe what happened is that at
some point after a archive
posted my Arena papers in Prior fraud
rang ideas or
Rangers and co-workers road to archives
saying we are going to sue you if you
don't do something because this is not
true okay and so they did not want to
get sued they didn't want to pay lawyers
to defend against what would have been a
frivolous lawsuit because
defamation means that you're accusing
somebody of something that is not true
if you're accusing somebody of Fraud and
it is true it's not defamation but also
it's a private in the private car if I
say you know Jorge likes to take you
know high altitude balloons and push
monkeys out of them then that's your
private citizen if I say your research
is wrong that you published in a journal
and I say that is that has elements of
fraud that it doesn't meet the standard
of death at least in the United States
they might claim because it was probably
nature there's different states and I
didn't say private fraud the initial
paper to physical see was basically
saying look there is this anomalies that
I cannot explain they don't prove fraud
for sure yeah but the fact that they are
not releasing the data when they
you know specifically say in the
published paper the data are available
and they are refusing to release them
that's a very big red flag yeah
yeah let's talk about journals for a
second
um before we finish up we have a couple
more segments uh that I just wanted to
ask you some existential questions I
know you usually like to answer these
types of things but I'll ask just one
with your forbearance but before I do
that
um you are known for the creation of the
of the H index
um can you describe what motivated you
to do that and uh what what it's what
it's become and where you might see it
going it's not the only of its kind but
it's certainly been very influential you
can find on Google Scholar you can find
what's your H index I think my age index
I think it's uh 69 maybe yeah that's
quite sure all right Elon Musk approves
uh so uh so tell me what what how did
this uh how did this come about yeah
I've always been interested in objective
criteria for judging scientists as
opposed to opinions so I always used to
look up citations of people when we're
considering for hiring and so on and so
forth
in the old days I had to go to the
library and look at this big box I don't
know if you still remember those uh I
found them extremely informative and so
you know but it's a lot of information
and to collect all that information and
discuss it
it gets cumbersome and then you know I I
just started and it was at the same time
the web of science was coming
online and so you could find the
citations online and I found that there
was this nice way to
compress a lot of information into a
single number that has a lot more
information at other single numbers
for example the number of applications
by itself can tell you very little the
number of total number of citations by
itself can tell you very little because
of various reasons right and so
I used this for two years I shared it
with my colleagues and then at some
point I wrote the preprint I didn't know
what to do with it
and
somebody contact me from Germany
[Music]
experiment that is named Manuel Cardona
who was
an extremely
prolific writer and good signed
excellent scientist and he had heard of
it through word of mouth and so that was
very interesting and well that time I
have already written a little pre-print
that I had circulated among colleagues
but I didn't know what to do with it so
when I got this email from this person
in Germany I decided to post it on
archive and
I posted an archive again not knowing
what I would publish it or not publish
and I started getting calls from
journalists asking me about it for some
reason I thought wait a minute I mean
I've written very many more interesting
papers whatever you think calls on this
1989 paper yeah right and
um yeah so well there's something the
phenomenon because you're not on social
media there's a phenomenon of you know
it's called uh it's called gamification
so you want to see after this video is
posted I'll uh I'll see how many thumbs
up the video got I'll compare it to when
I have Felix flicker on and that's a
reminder to everyone to not only
subscribe you know that only 80 only 20
of the people watching actually click
subscribe so please do subscribe please
leave a thumbs up we want to have more
conversations with brilliant luminaries
but that's a gamification Facebook
Twitter they're all these things and it
kind of maybe came about as a social
phenomenon although you didn't intend to
become a social scientist but you did
and now we make the basis for hiring or
at least in part not in entirely but I
wonder how you feel about that as well
but that's a conversation yeah
it's a long conversation but I have
mixed feelings about it let's say right
I mean I think it's very useful for
getting a quick impression of somebody
but you certainly have to look much
further and look at the details and it
can be very amazing necessary but not
sufficient no no and it can be
misleading also so it's there's some
danger so how has it been misused in
your opinion
or give an example I just think that you
can have very different profiles of
Publications somebody that writes papers
just by themselves or with a couple of
co-workers other people that ride with a
group of 10 or 50 or 100 people and
their age index can be the same but
their contributions can be very
different and so if you just rely on the
H index and don't take into account
that factory you can be misled very very
many very age since PhD uh you know yeah
institutions PhD I did I did discuss
that in my original paper and that's
that's easy to take care of because I
basically defined actually an index with
a ratio between the age index and the
number of years since the first
publication which kind of normalizes for
and what about field differences you
know my field you might have no papers
for several years your experiment gets
built you take data you write a dozen
papers right of course it's field
dependent you should really not compare
agent this is across very different
fields it's dangerous yes what about
across continents and different uh you
know institutional biases that may be
present I don't think that's so
important I think within like on this
matter physics I would
happily compare each indices of people
in the U.S or China or Europe or
wherever when I researched my first book
losing the Nobel Prize I Came Upon some
statistics that it was very rare it
almost never happened that someone won
the Nobel Prize but had not been elected
to say the National Academy of Sciences
are there other correlations that have
been uh observed by you and others about
the say the Nobel Prize or admission
into the National Academy or other
things like that that you're aware of
with the age index of me yeah
well in particular Manuel Cardona who
was the one that got very interested in
this initially that's the first thing he
did he calculated the age index of
everybody that had been a surprise or
Escape is the National Academy in the
last few years and it's a fun
correlation
so there is obviously some code yeah and
we have we have standards here when we
go for promotion every three years to
get a 50 raise every month or whatever
we get you know they'll say this and it
becomes exponentially hard to grow right
it starts to start to saturate that's
what's attractive about it yeah I think
one of the things attractive that when
you are starting it's easy to increase
your age by one right it's fun right I
got an email from Google Scholar every
week I just went up by one I'm 51 now uh
which is my age so that's pretty cool uh
so age since PhD is about 25 so we'll
see if I could ask the master for that
uh Jorge we don't have that much time
left you've been so generous with your
time first of all
um I did a video previously and which I
mentioned uh some things I want to give
you a chance to respond you said that
there were some important errors that
the audience will be left with I'd be
remiss as a host if I didn't ask you I'm
sorry please correct me I do not
remember the all the details the one
thing I do remember is that you did not
make a clear distinction which we have
done in our conversation today between
com What's Understood to be conventional
superconductors and unconventional
superconduct fair enough you did not
make the decision and that's very
important I understand that the
cooperates everybody accepts and beliefs
are unconventional the hydrides are
everybody believes are the conventional
BCS mechanism and I disagree with
um so the last question I was going to
ask you are you going to try to
um patent the H index like DS and all
our pat down just kidding Jorge just
kidding uh but there is one question I
always ask my guest if you're willing to
uh to to sort of address it it's it's an
existential question and it owes to the
namesake of the uh of the organization
I'm the associate director of which is
called the Arthur C Clarke Center for
human imagination and Sir Arthur said
many things you've heard me say this in
a faculty meeting quoting after him that
for every expert there's an equal and
opposite expert um he used to say things
like that and he also said the following
I'll give you two of his quotes and then
I want you to respond to one or both he
said any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
Magic I don't ask you first what is the
most magical thing in all of physics
that if we we were to summarize what
Humanity has come up with in physics as
Feynman said it was the atomic
hypothesis that was like the coolest
thing the most important thing the most
basic fundamental truth that could be
expressed in the fewest words Jorge to
you what is the most magical thing that
you've ever encountered as a scientist
oh that's a really tough question look I
I mean if you ask me about dollar
physics what I find the most amazing in
some sense is Maxwell's equations I just
love my consecrations I mean the fact
that he could express
so much and so many different phenomena
in those four equations I think it's
just a miracle yeah and
um and of course he was I often point
out that his original model like Hubble
uh in some sense was flawed right he
believed in these vortices
it was very intuitive very physical
mechanically I appreciate that very much
it wasn't based on very formal
mathematics it was based on physical
intuition and I think that is really
really important very good there is one
subject that we didn't I don't even know
you mentioned this issue about hype and
yeah yeah that's where it comes from I
just want to say that I think there's a
big problem with
the way research is funded and people
are driven to make these claims and type
things because of funding and I don't
know I think there there should be
possible improvements in the way science
is funded so that not so much funds
taxpayers funds are wasted on hype that
is not real yeah I agree with you and
part of the mission of this podcast
which you know you may have looked at
maybe once in your life but
um I do it because the public pays our
salary right so not just because
Republic uh University professors but
every scientist in America and around
the world is supported at some level by
his or her government institution now
what do we get out of that as a taxpayer
I find we don't give back very much to
the taxpayers we say we're doing
something very esoteric right you can't
understand it right
um and uh even if you could understand
it I have better things to do with my
time I think that's horrible not only
for the public who pays ours Valerie but
for scientists as well because the
minute the public loses confidence in
what we're doing they're going to stop
funding us so it's very dangerous I'm
glad you brought that up I call it the
academic media hype complex which is
that we have these media Offices here
and University of Rochester has a media
office right very powerful one yeah so
once you start going
um and then you get a hint and then and
then maybe you need to get you know 10
years or maybe a graduate student needs
a postdoc or maybe the postdoc music
it's very very tempting and it's so hard
as Feynman said in his famous essay at
Caltech commencement in 1964 or five or
whatever he said you know I hope you
never have to sacrifice your integrity
to uh to get attention to your results
or to what you do as a scientist because
that when that happens
not only will your own Integrity be
compromised but the Public's confidence
in how Integrity is maintained in
science will be undermine anyway Jorge
hers professor of physics you predate Me
by by some years I've been privileged to
know you for 19 years now it's our 19th
anniversary and uh I just want to say I
thank you for your integrity and on your
courage and I always say one one last
piece of advice although I hate I know
you hate to do these things but I can't
resist
um the name of the podcast is called
into the impossible which is another
quote of Sir Arthur C Clarke who said
the following he said the only way to
know what's the limits of the possible
is to go beyond them into the impossible
and I like to re-invert that and say
Jorge if you could talk to 20 year old
Jorge Hirsch what one piece of advice
would you give him to give him the
courage to do as you've done to go into
the impossible
is that the question that's a question
yeah well you're teleported for 30
seconds back to see young Jorge
I'm sorry I wasn't prepared for this I
am
look I I find myself very fortunate to
have
stumbled upon things that I think I
would never have imagined that
it made me understand things that
I never understood would there have been
a way to make things so that I would
have made more progress in getting
others to pay attention and
join in trying to understand these
things and I probably wasn't
good enough at doing that and I don't
know perhaps I would advise my younger
self to try to do that better fair
enough well Jorge you've been an
inspiration to many of us throughout
your career I find you not to be
disagreeable at all or whatever you were
accused of in this uh in this letter
nailed to the cathedral door of physics
in the Cathedral of New York City the
New York Times whatever that is um thank
you so much I do want to again extend a
request to my listening audience a
couple of requests one is to sign up for
my mailing list where you can get a
ferromagnetic sample of the early
universe that's 4.3 billion year old a
fell in Argentina of all places uh Campa
de Cielo which Jorge can pronounce
better than me and it was found of about
500 years ago the natives used it for
tools and so forth we now use it uh to
to talk about the formation of the solar
system and the dust that's contained
within our galaxy but more than that I
encourage you if you have a edu address
email address sign up for my mailing
list Brian keating.com and you will
guarantee to win one of these and if you
don't have a time either your email
address sign up anyway I give away a
hundred of these on a regular basis so
you can still win second of all is if
anybody is in contact with Professor
Diaz I would love to have him on the
podcast to
um to address some of the conversation
that I've had about him and others have
had about him and my last request is to
leave a thumbs up on this uh on this
podcast or wherever you're listening to
it leave a review if you like to have uh
more guests on that are doing the The
Cutting Edge at the highest level
research that you could imagine I will I
will let you know also I should tell you
uh Jorge I had a guest on David
Friedberg who is a billionaire investor
an incredible intellect and when he was
on he was on in February before the
announcement and he claimed that he
would uh he would cut off his right arm
to get room temperature
superconductivity so David I think Jorge
a great deal of gratitude for saving
your Rider anyway that's all from the
into the impossible Studios thanking you
so much stay tuned for the next episode
right here
foreign